So yesterday, we played clips for you of this
absolutely ridiculous phone call that Donald
Trump made to the Georgia secretary of state,
asking them to find eleven thousand seven
hundred and eighty votes and then saying,
come on, guys, I just need 11000 votes to
win Georgia.
And certainly that call is impeachable.
Donald Trump should be impeached for that.
He's not going to be I don't think, anyway,
he could be impeached after leaving office.
But it doesn't seem that there is a political
desire for impeachment.
But one of the very interesting things that
has come out of it is that Georgia Secretary
of State Brad Raffensperger, who was on that
call, he was the one being pressured and he
is a Republican being pressured to find a
way to give Donald Trump the state of Georgia.
He said it's unlikely we would investigate
or investigate criminally or ask criminal
charges to be brought because we have a conflict
of interest.
We were involved in the call, but it is certainly
something criminal investigation and possibly
even charges that an Atlanta area district
attorney could do.
And this is once again, it's just the tip
of the iceberg of what we may see once Donald
Trump is out of office.
And, of course, this should be investigated.
Here is the Georgia secretary of state, Republican
Brad Raffensperger, explaining, since he's
involved in this, he really shouldn't be part
of the investigation.
And he's right about that, but says that there
are others, including the Atlanta area district
attorney, that might be the right outfit to
investigate.
David Worley, a Democratic member of the state
election board, which Hugh Chair has asked
you to open an investigation into the call.
Will you open that investigation?
I believe that because I had a conversation
with the president, also had a conversation
with our chief investigator after we did the
signature match order of Cobb County last
week.
There may be a conflict of interest.
I understand that the Fulton County district
attorney wants to look at maybe that's the
appropriate venue for him to go.
So the first question and we'll go through
this sequentially, the first question is what
crimes might Trump have committed here?
And it's actually a long list.
And I'm not saying Trump will face charges.
I'm saying the list of possible crimes is
long federal laws against solicitation of
election fraud, I would argue were broken.
To prove it, you need to know intent.
But and that is hard to prove.
But just because something can't be proven
in court doesn't mean that, colloquially speaking,
you and I can't say yet.
Trump did that a federal laws against conspiracy
to intimidate, threaten, injure or oppress
any person of rights secured by the Constitution.
A Georgia state law against solicitation of
election fraud arguably was broken and Georgia
state law against willfully tampering with
an elector list, voter certificate, ballot
box, voting machine, tabulating equipment,
or to solicit others to commit such tampering.
So, as I told you before, with other Trump
investigations, I don't think this is going
to go very far.
But it may be yet another thorn in Trump's
side once he leaves office.
I think the most realistic scenario is not
Trump ever gets perp walked in handcuffs,
not Trump is even ever criminally charged
with anything.
I think the most likely scenario, if I'm being
just, you know, not hyperbolic, but but but
sort of conservative in my thinking with you
is there will be investigations into Trump
and his organization that will be a thorn
in Trump's side for years to come.
Now, another interesting aspect of this.
Why was the call recorded to begin with?
We know now that the Georgia officials on
the call did the recording and they did it
because of their knowledge that Donald Trump
previously has lied about the content of phone
calls.
So the recording was almost like an insurance
policy for them.
Assuming Trump would later lie about what
was said, they wanted a record to be able
to say, here's what was actually said.
So it's all completely embarrassing.
And, you know, if only we could have seen
this coming right.
Like if back in 2016 when when we were all
sounding the alarm and unfortunately there
were some on the left and right who were saying
it won't be that bad.
Trump for four years might even get us a true
progressive in 2020 that we would all be happy
with.
Trump will shake things up.
He'll sort of bring a different approach.
It has certainly been different, there's no
doubt about that.
But it has been an absolute and complete disaster,
regularly attacking in authoritarian fashion
multiple endless aspects of our democratic
systems.
And undoubtedly, Trump should be impeached
after the fact for this.
There's no question whatsoever on the merits
whether he will or won't be.
I don't know.
Is it even worth doing?
I mean, listen, as I said before, there is
a duty to impeach if you believe an impeachable
action has taken place.
And we sort of have.
To separate the potential outcome, which is
not going to be very much from from the duty
to do what is right as far as Congress is
supposed to do, but at this point, we're at
a loss and it's simply an emergency to get
rid of this guy.
We're down
to 15 days.
We
are down to
the last 15 days.